Christina come on it's her birthday it's
her birthday do you want to get a
dolphin at home no we can't no oh your
birthday's officially over now it's
midnight it's a birthday week
what
[Music]
what's up believe nation welcome to day
6 of our trip which is Nina's birthday
happy birthday Nina we are in Grand
Cayman Island we're gonna do one of the
tours doing the dolphin swim and
stingrays swim and right now we're gonna
get some food do celebrate
Nina turning 21 it's a bottle homophily
yeah the ship is moving a lot how'd you
sleep last night Nina not bad
this is our last day in Port before
tomorrow at sea and then back to Miami
where we kick it off
[Music]
we found the kids where's Nathan look
who it is
hello mister good morning how you doing
good
alright so round one for me
raisin brain with bananas mushrooms in
the chocolate whatever that is and Nina
got some birthday chicken congee is it
still salty yeah it's okay
and some coffee and some water hmm more
congee round - Nina's liking her chicken
congee huh juices like soup anything
warm liquidy just got my coffee still
doing soymilk even though I did a whole
bunch of dairy yesterday starting off a
little bit lighter in the morning no
dairy
we finished our breakfast gonna head
down back to the cabin and then get
ready to hit up where are we again Grand
Cayman Island
[Music]
so for Nina's birthday I got us a deep
tissue massage for tomorrow for a date
see I also told the kids to go make a
special birthday card for Nina and they
asked our step and cure to cap cap in
Stuart Jason to bring a bottle of
champagne in tonight I have to be good
for dinner
so planning a few surprises for the wife
if you love Nina put something the
comments below - where's your happy
birthday and I hope today goes really
really well are we ready they don't want
to go yeah they have to go tell them we
have to go all right kids are here ready
to go oh did you give it did you see
okay happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you happy birthday dear Nina
happy birthday to you thank you guys you
came up with something
[Music]
so we have to get on tenders today the
only day that is tenders because we
can't actually dock in the city so
getting ready hopefully not too bumpy
and we get to our stingray destination
[Music]
so we made it we're gonna do Stingray
City first it's about a half hour boat
ride out in an hour with the stingrays
half hour back then we're gonna do
dolphins but they made a policy of no
phones or cameras allowed for the
Dolphins because they want you to ply
their stock so I'll vlog the Stingray
and then maybe add some pictures of the
Dolphins if you buy them what do you
think Ritchie's not happy he wants the
blog which is very upset we'll get some
quality seaweed buddy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go Richie come on get in come on
Nina
there we go it's a little cold we're
good having fun
all right let's go find our Stingray
friend it's here it's here
okay good job is there
hi-five nice all right Dinah's up
Christina come on it's her birthday it's
her birthday
[Laughter]
what do you think
[Music]
that was fun yep we're gonna head back
to the dolphin cove swim with dolphins
not allowed to feel their breath that
people get some pictures alright hit
record dolphin we gotta put on her stuff
for the lockers including poem selves is
by checking out and hopefully wall
splices and pictures from the fun
awesome time now see about the pictures
Hayden how was it mister good there we
go how was your birthday with the
dolphin Xena
you like it happy birthday how much are
the pictures gonna cost us gonna
negotiate all right you can negotiate
your Nina Carmichael but you shouldn't
have to do it on your on your birthday
what was the best part of today
dolphin best part of the day
the dolphin singing your happy birthday
got a discount $200 down on the pictures
3:30 instead of 5
what 5:30
[Music]
what was the best part of today Hayden
the dolphin alright eleven do you want
to get a dolphin at home no we can't no
we actually have a saltwater pool yeah
but still
[Music]
[Music]
I am to get in this line so we can get
back on the boat
whoo we made it that long line we still
made it on the next boat well we keep
you the last boats together for more
anyway we're here we have to go there
shower and then dinner to celebrate
[Music]
I just crank called the kids telling
them to come over but we went through
about five minutes of back and forth
over who was on the phone it was really
fun crank calling them and now that
she'd become went over soon so we can go
to there
[Music]
you guys got crank called a little bit
there huh yeah the point is you guys
fell for it hardcore you fell for it so
bad we know if hey didn't pick up the
phone though I don't know what if I
would have fooled them he's too used to
that stuff all right so our family and
the kids all wanted to go to the buffet
so Nina and I are going to enjoy our
romantic
with no kids and no family and that's
amazing I wish I could say I planned it
that way
I totally planned it that way it was
totally planned for us to spend the
dinner with no kids right yeah all right
this is our huge table for two people
let's enjoy so we are on our way to dock
to Miami
we've got tomorrow's a day at seat we're
gonna do some filming do some relaxing
and then next day one day Miami then we
go home
so this is our official last day in in a
port we've been enjoying our dinner and
we call for the kids so that we can
celebrate
Niska
[Music]
[Applause]
we had a little bit of talking moose
cake but now we're heading up into the
14th floor here's some real dessert
[Music]
that penis plate lots of healthy fruit
and I got peach cobbler with caramel ice
cream jelly beans
Santos ah what did they can you know
back to the room
[Music]
oh my goodness oh wow
well hello Oh what Wow how did that
happen
Wow I don't even know how that happened
huh hey imagine that just a little bit
of covert operations you know sneaking
around behind Yuma's back to make things
happen one more surprise oh my goodness
what is that so tomorrow noon we have a
date
for a couples massage deep tissue 15
minutes long we should turn the cameras
off at this point
birthday champagne all right believe
nation it is time in his midnight Oh
your birthday's officially over now
it's midnight it's a birthday week
what listen birthday day was enough to
plan today was an awesome day I really
enjoyed the stingray and the dolphin I
never I'd never done either those before
I've seen a bunch of liars and promos
for them but be numb to experience was
awesome the minute with with Nina on her
birthday scene Hayden freaked out in a
good way joy and excitement was really
great
and then I'll just the birthday
celebrations the little surprises
everything went according to plan which
is always good because invariably
usually they one or two things is not
gonna go to plan but everything worked
out really well so that always makes you
happy when the when the planes go
according the plan and we made a special
day for the wife so makes me happy you
have a good day yeah good we're gonna
enjoy our massage tomorrow day at sea
gotta make some filming for the channel
oh man we'll see we'll see what else we
do we've got a whole day of just
stealing the boat before when the Miami
and then coming home so thank you guys
for joining another vlog of our
Caribbean vacation hopefully you guys
enjoyed - we believe in you you continue
to believe and whatever you want or is
we'll see you soon
much love